bien écouter bonne année à tous d'abord
commençons l'année par ce bureau
politique et un bureau politique
important que que nous voulions vous
commenter sur laquelle nous pourrions
répondre à des questions avec guillaume
larrivé qui qui m'accompagnent dans ce
point presse donc ce bureau politique
apporté quasiment exclusivement certain
nombre de mesures d'ordre interne mais a
porté sur le plan politique
exclusivement sur 7 sur les dossiers de
la réforme constitutionnelle
alors comme vous le comme vous l'avez
peut-être où on est en train de vous
distribuez un texte a été adopté par le
bureau politique
après un débat très dense un débat j'ai
pu le noter qui a duré quasiment plus
d'une heure et demie c'est un débat dans
lequel il ya eu beaucoup beaucoup de
prises de position plus d'une vingtaine
de prises de position ou de déclarations
des membres du bureau politique et qui
s'est soldée par un vote sur ce texte
un vote qui a permis sur 58 votants
d'obtenir 5h51 50 51 votes positifs cinq
votes négatifs et 2 2 abstentions
donc c'est une unanimité est très très
large autour de ceux de ce texte
évidemment il ya débat il y aura
toujours débat au sein des républicains
et ce débat était de qualité alors que
kaka tondi et ce sur quoi apporter le
débat nous avons d'abord noter que
évidemment les républicains demandé des
mesures fermes en face de la situation
d'aujourd'hui et qu'on était en droit de
les attendre dès le mois de janvier que
nous ne les avons pas eu que ces mesures
n'ont pas été prises et que ce serait
évidemment incompréhensible qu'elle ne
soit pas prise après c'est le drame du
mois de novembre qui a touché qui a
touché la france et que nous exigeons
bien évidemment des garanties pour la
sécurité des français que nous sommes
soucieux aussi de la cohérence de nos
positions nous avons affirmé nous avons
réaffirmé à plusieurs reprises
guillaume est bien placé pour le dire
notamment lors de proposition de loi
nous avons fait des propositions très
précises concernant une augmentation de
la sécurité une augmentation du nombre
d'instruments juridiques me
la disposition des forces de l'ordre et
de la justice nous n'avons pas été
entendus jusqu'à maintenant où un
certain nombre de nos propositions sont
reprises et par souci de cohérence donc
la réforme constitutionnelle
nous pourrions être amenés à la voter
donc nous avons pris une position
précise nous voterons la réforme
constitutionnelle mais nous demandons un
certain nombre de points
ces points sont ceux là il y en a
exactement 4
le premier point c'est que une réforme
constitutionnelle ne vaut que par
l'application de cette réforme
qu'est-ce qu'il ya exactement texte
constitutionnel par principe et général
et puis après il ya des lois
d'application
nous demandons qui est une loi organique
d'application de la réforme
constitutionnelle concernant l'article
34 et que au moment où les
parlementaires auront à prendre leur
décision définitive au moment du vote du
débat sur la réforme constitutionnelle
nous soyons évidemment informés des
textes d'application de ces mêmes
réformes
il est bien naturel qu'à partir du
moment notamment lorsqu une opposition
fait confiance à une majorité pour un
texte elle demande l'ensemble du texte
et nous souhaitons avoir l'ensemble du
texte d'application de la réforme
constitutionnelle ce sera pour nous la
seule manière de nous assurer de la
valeur effective de la mise en oeuvre
effective de l'effectivité des mesures
qui sont proposés dans cette réforme
constitutionnelle donc nous lions la
réforme constitutionnelle avec le texte
d'application de la réforme
constitutionnelle
nous demandons que deuxième demande nous
demande donc la déchéance de nationalité
soit prévue avec les mêmes le même
spectre le même champ d'application le
même champ de deux d'incrimination que
celles qui sont prévues à l'article 25
du code civil
donc c'est un champ assez qui précise
pour la déchéance de nationalité pour
des binationaux qui ont été naturalisés
donc on étend dans la constitution aux
binationaux qui ne sont pas naturaliser
aux binationaux de naissance nous
demandons que ce soit les mêmes
conditions et ces conditions sont
énumérées à l'article 25
le code civil nous demandons aussi que
la déchéance de nationalité qui est
prononcée par par décret nous demandons
que cette échéance déchéance de
nationalité soit prononcée au moment de
la de la peine au moment où la personne
est condamnée par la par la justice la
déchéance de nationalité
vas y à ce moment là et pas en fin de
peine parce que ça voudrait dire que au
fond si quelqu'un est condamné à 10 ans
ou 20 ans de prison voire voire plus
la déchéance de vaudrey qu'après elle
doit valoir au même moment
évidemment il ya exécution de la peine
dans le pays en france ou ailleurs il ya
des conventions qui le précise mais
après l'exécution de la peine il ya
évidemment la déchéance mais la défiance
a été décrété elle a été arrêtée au
moment de la peine et puis dernier point
c'est dans le cadre de la de l'état
d'urgence il ya deux volets il ya un
volet état d'urgence et un volet
déchéance de nationalité dans le cadre
de l'état d'urgence peu dans la réforme
constitutionnelle on puisse bien prévoir
par le texte qui convient que il ya des
possibilités de surveillance notamment
par bracelet électronique conditions de
rétention qui soient des décisions
d'ordre administratives et pas
uniquement d'ordre judiciaire pour des
raisons évidentes de d'efficacité donc
ce sont des demandes que nous formulons
très solennellement à françois hollande
et à la majorité pour que nous soucions
de demandes et on verra au moment du
débat parlementaire
ce que sera ce que la majorité dira de
ces de ces demandes qui ne sont des
demandes qui sont acceptables bien
veiller à ce que ces demandes soient
évidemment acceptable c'est pas des
demandes retouches quoi on n'est pas en
train de faire une sorte de l'amalgamé
en considérant qu'on est d'accord
enfin on sait jamais avec des demandes
inacceptables ont pas du tout dans cet
état d'esprit on est dans l'état
d'esprit d'un vote nous demandent de la
transparence et de la clarté sur les
conditions de ceux de ceux de ce vote
enfin nous demandons un changement
complet de la politique pénale du
gouvernement alors des choses qui sont
en préparation on n'a pas les textes ils
ont été transmis au conseil d'état un
certain nombre de publications en en
fait en en fait écho hier et est
aujourd'hui nous demandons que y ait une
fin de toutes remises automatiques ou
réductions de peine en lien avec les
activités taurines terroristes on
demande une pénalisation de la
consultation régulière des sites
jihadistes on demande une mise en oeuvre
de la rétention de sûreté pour les
terroristes condamnés à leur sortie de
prison appuyé par l'ouverture de centres
de déradicalisation c'est des
propositions que nous avions déjà fait
y'a pas de surprise c'est des
propositions que nous avons faites au
moment de la convention et notamment sur
la sécurité et nous réaffirmons notre
volonté que il ya un changement complet
total de la politique pénale du
gouvernement et la politique pénale
menée par françois hollande
enfin les républicains demandent exige
la mise en place d'une commission d'
enquête parlementaire sur l'ensemble des
faits des événements terroristes qui
sont déroulées sur notre sol depuis le
mois de janvier 2015 il ya eu beaucoup
vous l'avez remarqué
peut-être certains d'entre vous il y ont
participé mais beaucoup d'émissions de
télévision beaucoup d'articles de
journaux aussi beaucoup d'émissions de
télévision dans quête sur ce qui s'est
passé beaucoup de fêtes ont été révélées
beaucoup de choses pose question il est
naturel que la représentation nationale
qui se posent les mêmes questions
puissiez obtenir une réponse est donc
nous souhaitons nous exigeons nous
demandons nous l'avions déjà fait deux
demandes dont il est président le
président larcher était là les
présidents de groupe aussi nous
demandons à ce que la commission
denquête une commission denquête soient
réunies au plus vite les français
évidemment un droit de vérité sur ces
sujets là la vérité permet aussi de
progresser
nous voulons se voir comment les
décisions de l'état en puces se mettre
en place à ce moment là voilà ce qui a
été dit
j'ai eu beaucoup de discussions beaucoup
de discussions sur les
sujet sur les sujets de l'article 25 du
code civil beaucoup de discussions de
cette nature beaucoup de discussions
aussi sur la déchéance de nationalité
d'un bureau politique qui étaient dans
ce cas était franc qui s'est passé dans
une ambiance c'est pas de la langue de
bois
cordial et donc je souhaitais vous le
dire et ce texte a été voté par 51 voix
sur 58 participants